hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to power washing simulator
or power wash simulator not power
i can power wash mars time to put the
water on mars to good use as the rover
needs to clean
[Music]
i've never played this game before ever
and now it's my favorite game
what oh my god
[Laughter]
i never in a million years did i think
that the first game
well not the first game obviously but a
game that would take me to the surface
of mars
would be power wash simulator i love
this game
it is amazing it might be the greatest
game ever made
the x-ray spectrometer the x-ray
spectrometer
i'm watching the x-ray spectrometer's
drill oh
the rock analyzer
i'm watching you
[Laughter]
the drill is clean oh my god i've never
been happier
i've legitimately never been happier
there's no point in my life
that has ever been happier than i am
right now i only wish to clean you
why are you green what's green on you i
suppose i'll figure out when i get to
that part
but i want to clean this very
methodically it's not clean it's not
clean
not yet anyway oh yeah
i gotta get on all the crevices good
thing there's unlimited water here
oh yeah i have never been happier
all right let's get a yes yeah slight
angle on this
oh yeah oh yeah get that martian dust
off of there
someday i'll be on you you know i've
said this before but i don't think
people actually believe me if there was
a volunteer program to go to mars for
like colonists or something even if the
chance of death was like 99
i would i would be first in line or if i
wasn't first in line i would fight for
first in line
i would be in line no matter what i
would volunteer in a heartbeat
this is combining several very
satisfying things to me power washing is
satisfying i do like that
on the uh redacted channel we did uh
have a bit of a power washing adventure
but
also just this is just truly a delight i
think i can do a wider
yeah the sound is good too
nice and loud girthy some good sounds
oh how am i breathing by the way
that don't matter i'm on mars
i hope this thing is weatherproof i
don't know if they designed it to be
waterproof considering that
it doesn't rain on mars but you know who
knows it's got to be
somewhat environmentally sealed i
suppose i don't know
they built this thing tonka tough so i'm
assuming that it's pretty good
oh oh oh
mashed camera oh i'm really knocking
them out now
oh
it really does it a good job lee
unlike how i said those words this does
do it
a good job lee i'm okay my brain cells
are
are probably dying from the lack of
oxygen in this uh planet because
clearly there's no uh there's no air
here but
honestly if i have to die and make the
last thing i do
wash this rover it will have been a good
death and it will have been a good life
i keep thinking there's like an animal
on the ground but it's just you i will
clean you too
but it seems like your rotors are
probably dusting yourself off if you
didn't know they flew a helicopter on
mars you better have known that
it also wouldn't be this bright i don't
think i
love it and i oh yeah
get in there oh get in there oh yeah get
in there
we are looking good why is tire spelled
with a y
you know what you do whatever you want
rovi what if i get a different
long extension oh hell yeah for the real
power i don't know what the difference
is
i love the clackity-clack oh yeah the
swirlo
oh this is what i was looking for oh
hell yeah the swirlo
get you i'll get you you want some too
you want something to i'll wash you
fine yeah the swirlo is really what's
gonna get the things like
in the nooks and all the nooks and the
tiny devices oh yeah oh yeah
there we go now we're really getting it
this is
unbelievably satisfying it says 87
clean so i must be missing something
pretty significant
like i would think anyway because it
really seems like there's more here
oh there oh there we go okay i'm getting
the tippy tops of those
yeah getting the top side of everything
oh the low gravity baby
yeah cause it's kind of hard to tell
what's wet and what's dirty
well that was dirty apparently i don't
think i'm gonna be able to get down
unless i can go prone which i would love
to be able to be full tactical on this
can go prone
but i don't think that's an option man
this is great
okay uh cleaning liquids i don't have
any cleaning liquids i just have water
weird let me go full let me try to get
as much coverage as possible i don't i
don't know what i'm missing exactly
is it a thing where like only certain
amount of pressure can clean certain
things and there's just like some things
in here that are
too gunked up to get off with a wide
nozzle that doesn't seem like it
i mean maybe it is the thing where i
just have to get this uh freaking
get you come here are you where are you
going where you going
where you going here okay you're coming
over here okay good good i'll be here
too
somewhere okay
ah i was gonna get you all right i can't
wash you
i mean it looks pretty done at least it
looks
i can't see any dirt here
it really doesn't look like it i don't
know if there's like a list of
you know okay here we go sensors
oh hatch is this openable can you open
this
hatch oh oh there we go
okay and then wheel hubs and hatch
so there's a way to open it apparently i
don't see hatch
hatch hatch
i might just be big stupid you know this
is wheel hubs i know it's got to be this
one back here
but there's like only certain angles
that i can approach it at
oh there we go okay so that's good
enough i don't know where the hatch is
but i got pretty much everything so
that was delightful that was great but
now i need to actually do this as a job
i need to make money okay let's start
off with a wide
and we'll get to the details later
oh yeah look at that baby shine
look at that thing look at that thing
it's like it was never horribly abused
like some van that i don't know
no no you're talking about everybody hey
whatever it's okay i love taking care of
things like this
ooh saw my dream rv at the auctions all
creamy like a toffee pie on wheels
that's really weird i don't know whether
to drive it or lick it
again really weird who is talking to me
are these the voices in my head that i
need to ignore or is this something more
concerning
unfortunately i sold for a crazy amount
but the dream lives on that's great
whoever you are
i'm just giving it a quick once-over
rinse and then i'll go in for the
details
eventually i'll learn what are the
harder things to clean and i'll know to
get those faster
like the edges i bet there's definitely
going to be a rhyme and a reason to this
all right done i guess this
is very nice i'm not gonna lie
god i need that turbo nozzle that's the
real deal
whoa i can jump oh my god i can jump
holy i guess if you're in power
washing you gotta jump
yep purpose
oh look at the bird poop on this oh my
god
oh hey gnome what the hell there's a
removal van outside my neighbor's night
my nightmare neighbor's place they're
finally going whoever moves in there is
going to need a quality pressure washer
yeah i'll get you in a second i'm
working on my own stuff
you hush your face oh yeah
oh yeah this is primal i think our
ancestors used to have power washers
that's why this connects so deeply to my
psyche
ancient koreans you know and their power
washers it was definitely a thing this
is a dream
god who knew this game needed to exist
you got to go with that busy name or do
you need me to think some up
i'm phenomenal i thought of grouting
thomas for that tyler and she's never
looked
yeah she never looked back at you for
anything ever
oh yeah the quick switch oh yeah oh
that's good
yeah the problem with the white one is
it's too wide it doesn't really get
anything it's probably better for
finishing than starting because i have
to go through everything anyway
so i might as well do it with like the
15 degree because
that just allows me to get things good
like just
very i have to be a little slower but
it's a wide enough that it's more
efficient i think than the red one
this red one's such a tight beam it's
good for like spots and tough
tough patches but overall i still think
it kind of takes longer
i think for bang for your buck and time
efficiency it's probably gonna be
the the yellow nozzle 15 degrees
there's probably some qualifications
about distance pressure stuff like that
but it seems like you know the nozzle
the impact area gets bigger when you go
farther away
so i think it's that's pretty safe until
i get the turbo nozzle that'll be my
dream
one day i'll be able to afford a turbo
nozzle oh then my life's gonna change
for the better yeah windows seem to take
a little bit more pressure
which is fine i get it get these in
there yeah there we go that's what we're
talking about
blast those crevices and just a little
bit left on the grill i believe
let me just um getting some of it
yeah it's hard to tell on some of these
it's just like i don't know where it is
because i can't exactly see it but this
is the last piece i know
hey oh what else is left
what else is left window
window oh oh come on come on where where
where
bonnet body oh wing mirror the mirrors i
forgot about the mirrors oh jeez
of course how could i forget about the
mirrors
door still a little bit there man the
the
it is particular about these details
got it under the handles of course got
to get the handles
right nailed it is this extraordinary
power of doctor
the extraordinary dr power wash i got
your details from friend harper
could really do with a hand at my place
when you're free oh
could you now i cost money
oh god it shows a time lapse of your
progress oh wow
oh my goodness oh my goodness i love
that
pinged you the hundred dollars left over
from what you gave me that should help
you get off the ground i just met my new
neighbor over the fence grumbling about
his dirty backyard and give him a shower
it looks like you've got your first
customer
yay clean the back garden oh my god i
get an outdoor thing
oh my god i literally love this game i
can't
i literally can't say how much i love
this game it's fantastic
oh sorry i didn't mean to do that i
wanted to take this a little more
carefully
okay what do i have i have nothing i
don't know if i'm cleaning fluid
i'm just gonna go let's see
let's go try it with the green
oh look at that wood blast
yeah it is distant space so you do need
something so really there's no
there's no easy way to do this right
there's no
easy it all takes time i might as well
just use the yellow
i mean actually green did work
i know yellow is the only way to go
because you got to do it carefully
anyway because otherwise you'll be in a
situation like i'm in right now where
there's like a tiny tiny sliver left and
i don't know where there it is
so i might as well just do it
methodically and carefully
very carefully very methodically it's
the only way to do it
can i do this as a career is this
actually a career choice for me
like is this something that i could do
with my life it could have been a
professional power washer
is this what some people do in their
life because it's got to be very
satisfying
oh my goodness oh the oh
the lawn edging
oh my
do i need to wash the gravel i'll do it
power wash my nose please you think they
make a
power wash neti pot really blast it out
nice nice money 50 cents per
rock not bad not bad
might as well do it right the first time
that's what my dad taught me
don't half-ass it don't try to find an
easy way out
there's just sometimes you gotta do it
exactly the way it needs to be done and
there's no other way around it
there's also this one which like
guarantees that everything you hit
is definitely clean you just have to
make sure you hit everything
maybe this is better actually
i end up going through things multiple
times no matter what i do so
this is where if i had the turbo nozzle
god i i was spoiled with it
got it right off the bat i'll never have
it ever again probably gotta go buy it
but it costs thousand dollars or
something like that it's a nozzle after
all
tiny piece of metal like that oh you
know it's expensive maybe maybe i'm just
looking at it tactically wrong
maybe i need cleaner but i don't have
any cleaner
just get right in the angle maybe the
angle is important
this is barely doing a dent nowhere near
satisfying
i thought you could hide from me back
here no way
come on what are you thinking there we
go
that is what some people would refer to
as the good
stuff a true master uses all the tools
at their disposal
doesn't just relegate one tool for the
job no no there's a reason that i have
different ones
and it's to absolutely
give this the best clean that i possibly
could
trying to see where there's any spots
but i don't see spots
probably because i wasn't methodical
about it
there we go who's who needs methodical
get ready birds you're about to get
blasted
and they're drowning oh so sad
but at least they're clean
oh that looks bad anyway i'll get to you
in a second i
just started to edge this and i got
distracted what happened here
is this a mud wrestling pit what is this
supposed to be a
pond no no no that ain't no pond
let me tell you that much that ain't no
pond
that is not a pond the nightmare realm
or some very
fun very kinky memories happened here
but that's not my
job to judge florene and i would like to
would climb up and down that rock garden
all day pretend we were on rumble and
mount rushless and the pond was the
crater
rumbling mount rushless huh okay sure
you know what you don't need to text me
about your kinky adventures this is uh
just a job for me ma'am
i'm just here to clean that's all that's
that's all i care about i don't know
what these stains are i don't ask
i never ask about stains it just is what
it is what's up
do you do bikes i could do with someone
running the thing over my deadbeat dirk
bike
yeah just a second gotta take care of
the mud wrestling pit
[Music]
i have now made a decision red and green
are for fools
it is literally just yellow and or white
and green are for fools yellow and red
are the only tools you need
everything else is just a distraction
from the truth that's what all power
washers must
come to eventually the truth of the
clean
you're gonna go through it anyway you're
gonna go over it again and again if you
do any other tool you might as well just
do it right the first time i'm
sorry i didn't listen to the lessons of
my father he was right
i just gotta clean it i'm gonna be going
through all this again
just because i didn't do it the first
time that is my curse
because i'm an idiot i think the reason
that this game these games do
so well and are so satisfying is because
they really hearken into the dream of
you know home ownership
domestication all that stuff sure you
get the
wilderness survival simulators and
whatnot ah those are fine
sure give me a give me a hose simulator
any day
give me some powerful water strong water
anyway i'll take it
that's what i need that's what i want
it's what i yearn for
some people yearn for the call of the
wild i yearn for the call of the water
not the ocean though screw that the
powerful water the true power of water
the ocean ain't no ain't the water's
power nah this is it
that's the water's true potential here
i'm back on the train that a true master
uses all the tools at their disposal
but it's about using them correctly
that's the right way to go about it
that's what people really don't
understand about this
the art form of the real power washing
master i have such a
long way to go before i reach the road
of mastership but
we are all students
just of different crafts is there anyone
that speed runs this i bet
i just bet speed running power washing
oh
i would watch that i would i will after
i do this
i don't know if that's actually dirt or
if it's just a shadow
it might just be a shadow that i'm
fighting never mind
i'm dumb turns out i'm stupid
just because i'm a learner of life
doesn't mean that makes me any smarter
there we go this is so weird this is so
not like me i've never been this
meticulous about like anything in a game
i've never been super completionist
about things but for some reason this
like i am so about this
i am 100 about this this is
amazing and i love it and i want to do
it right why do i want to do this right
like why it's weird almost
oh i'm never going to be able to find
the these pond wall
cracks that i miss oh never mind i got
it because i'm very methodical
apparently holy crap
i love it oh
oh i'm super addicted to this i'm super
i'm
is bad this is bad oh this is
bad i got it brad
oh no this is going to ruin my life oh
guys get ready for like a 10 part
series of this oh my god i'm
i've reached the point where i don't
really have any like fascinating
commentary to say about this i mean i
will probably once i get more into the
game i'll have a lot of like
weirdly specific gripes about cleaning
like suddenly i'll be talking shop about
cleaning things
that's not me i don't know why i would
be doing that but i can sense that i'm
kind of getting in the direction of that
like i've already started griping about
not having my turbo nozzle and i just
like i really could use my turbo nozzle
right now
the first thing i'm gonna go buy is my
turbo nozzle because then i can get the
power of everything in the distribution
of at least like the 15 degree it'll be
like a 10 degree but then i won't have
to go through it again with the power
it'll just be power all the time and a
little bit of coverage
you know what i mean better get the
cracks
lots of cracks and crevices here well
this thing got grimy
they let this thing go how long are
things back here in this backyard
yeah you know a little preventative
maintenance would do them a long way i
mean i'm fine i like the job you know i
get paid to do what i do
and that's fine keep me in business but
at the same time man you gotta treat
your tool right
you gotta treat your tool right these
people just let things go to waste they
don't even barbecue do they i bet they
don't i bet they don't
all right that's good there oh this toy
car what is this a mini tesla
oh man what happened to them
what happened to their kids they go on
vacation for a year
okay oh god horrible spiraling
depression sure that explains a lot
made this whole power washing simulator
go real dark what was the game that like
had
weirdly dark things was it house flipper
which kind of reminds me of this game
it's not the same i
i don't think it's the same publisher
but it's like house flipper oddly enough
had like some
strangely dark tones to it
don't know why
there we go
you could tell that love was lost
considering this uh swing here hasn't
been used in a bit
hope it's water resistant i'm gonna have
to power wash a haunted house at some
point aren't i
that's really the only natural
conclusion of this like i don't know how
they got the nasa collab that's pretty
cool
like really awesome that they managed to
get that but
there's like the hor where's the outlast
collab you know washing up all the blood
from all the horror games
i mean there was that game viscera
cleanup detail which was kind of like
touching on the subject of like
the aftermath of horrible alien
invasions and whatnot
you know just having to clean up all the
bodies and stuff that is kind of a
reality of things
but uh when is this gonna mix with that
oh can you imagine power washing blood
oh that's gotta be so satisfying
talk about primal that's gotta be great
perfectly normal please someone agree
with me alexian
you agree with me right that's perfectly
normal things i want
right amazing
good this grimy underbelly what did they
do to the bottom of this
what kind of nasty stuff were these
people doing
oh it's so grody oh hey what
it's a cat
it's immune to my blasts it's immune
how are you immune to my blasts if i
blast you right up the pooper that
really does nothing to you that this is
not doing anything to you you're not
bothered by this at all
this game is suddenly terrible
completely unrealistic if i can't power
wash a cat
i am out this dirt finder general guy
harper shaw alleged dirt problem at a
local
local playground that's not the name of
my business get the name of my business
right and then maybe we'll talk
i know that i've been recording it
probably a lot longer than you guys have
seen
but just because i am thoroughly
enjoying this like i am
thoroughly enjoying this like damn it's
good
it's just very good
like my god it's good i
i don't know if you get i don't know if
it's even translating and you guys
seeing it but this game is just
i love it i kind of really actually love
it
unironically love this so much
let's see if i can hop up here oop there
we go
hi cat don't mind me which you haven't
been
even if i'm standing on you you do
provide me with some stability which i
think is the purpose of cats
sheds done shed roof
should be done
there's something i'm missing here
what's going on
why aren't you clean i said shed a roof
there's a big spot missing is it because
it's cat
are you on it better not be on it you're
ruining my day
you're ruining my day
you are ruining my day aren't you you're
ruining my day
oh you little piece of poop
how am i not done how is this not done i
swear you're done what am i missing
every nook every cranny it's so close
enough
oh just give oh okay there we go the
tiny crack from the underneath
that really great okay
almost done here god these people look
out their window and see their power
washer they just tired screaming at the
cat on the shed that won't die
or move it's probably a decoration
actually it's probably like a solid
decoration
i'm probably even more insane to them oh
you're gonna do this to me again aren't
you
freaking dog house roof with the mini
crevices
there we go that's what i thought okay
and uh the coup de gras oh the fence
over there i forgot about that okay
almost done
[Music]
i know i know i haven't said a lot i
know and hopefully there's been some
kind of like time lapse going on and my
face hasn't probably been an expression
of pure ecstatic joy
but i am having an incredible time like
i have this strange compulsion to finish
this
i've i very rarely it feels like i'm
working with my hands which is usually
the only situations where i get this
kind of sensation
but it feels like i'm actually
accomplishing something here
and i know that's the whole thing about
games is like you feel like you're doing
something and it's like
that maintaining that feeling is part of
the whole appeal of video games but just
like it really actually feels like i'm
doing something
but i will also try to hurry up
my girls can't wait to get out there uh
your girls like the mud wrestling
group that you have going on all right
trail is cleaned
we are 80 done let's get the rest of
this patio done
i'm getting excited because i know i'm
almost done and then i'm going to look
at this whole thing and i can't wait to
see the time lapse of this because i
thought the van was meticulous but that
only took like 10 minutes
this has been like a this has been like
a 40 45 minute adventure
in this one and i say adventure and i
mean adventure like this has been an
adventure
[Music]
patio's done oh it's real forgiving on
the patio when you have a little bit
extra
unlike some things shed
oh my god this umbrella oh the parasol
oh looking grody
okay don't mind my mad hops
whoo done it did not look done but it
was done
apparently
[Music]
and we are
what are we missing what are we missing
here's all poll
okay paris all poll
and that was that that's all that that's
all that
that's all that that's all that pond
liner
there we go okay pond liner on liner
pond liner pond
retaining wall cap still needs some okay
okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay oh
was it lawn edging oh
something here i've missed i don't know
what i don't see it
okay that's done one edging stepping
stone
that mrs stone stone
lawn engine one itching
london okay oh swing itself a roof
ah i didn't get the back that was it
okay all right okay that was it
huh there we go now we're talking
now we're finishing now we're getting it
there we go oh we're not done oh
what else are we missing what i'm
missing okay
bird house birdhouse control panel
food shelves okay so the birdhouse is
not oh it's not done
i thought it was done i thought i got
this the birds are still alive in there
i gotta drown them out
okay that's done i said food shelves are
not done
there we go control panel is not done
okay what else okay lawn mower oh the
lawn emoji
i'd forgotten all about you oh i didn't
even know
i didn't even i was jumping all over you
probably my shoes got you dirty up
that's okay i won't charge extra for
that i will
i absolutely will
did i get it what else is there what
else is there
fence post fence posts what fences which
fences
which fences fence oh how is this not
done
or did i not get this well i did not get
this
i thought i got that defense defense top
fence post okay there's one post left it
must be over here
oh god look at that thing
look at that go oh that's a good
oh that's a good that's a good
oh shop ah
heavy duty oh oh but i don't have the
money for that oh
professional duty oh we don't even have
that who even who even could afford that
not me
cleaner ah
oh cleaning liquids attached to soap
nozzles so i need a
soap nozzle right oh but the turbo
nozzle
this and that and then
cleaning liquids definitely
shouldn't i just get universal cleaner
shouldn't i just get
like a good bit of oh i can buy them all
oh of course i'll buy them all
oh of course are you kidding me of
course i would buy them all
okay but i'll get you later but now i
have the oh
oh oh i could oh
wow okay let me just go back to this
because i want to see
i'm just gonna because i just want to
test it out i know that i've been this
is a long ass episode maybe it hasn't
been because of the amount of
uh cutting but i just wanted to see okay
let's do the soap nozzle
let's do the universal cleaner
go for it
make my job easy on me why don't you
oh this ain't even a problem anymore the
use of chemicals to make my
life oh a dream
a dream look at this nonsense
look at this nonsense taking all the art
out of it though you know
really not appreciating for what it is
yeah sure okay it gets clean but you
know you don't really enjoy the
experience not nearly as satisfying
and let me swap it out for a metal
cleaner
oh instantaneously ah no universal
cleaner was fine
universal cleaner works why would you
use anything different
bam
just stand back and watch it work good
lord
[Music]
i don't know what else could possibly be
oh the wing mirrors i didn't get the uh
ah
god damn that was quick
[Music]
wow damn
easy you know it's almost too easy you
know it's not uh elegant
water air air and i gotta try one second
i literally love this i i don't shush
i love it
oh look at the clean look at the clean
and i'd still rather just use the other
the the freaking
yellow nozzle anyway okay i'm done i'm
done i'm done i'm gonna be here forever
i'm gonna be here forever i'm gonna be
here forever
that is power wash simulator fantastic
game
i literally haven't had that much fun
doing a menial labor thing
in a long long time so thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
play the shoot link in the description
below and hey
if you don't check out distractible i'm
going to power wash your soul right out
of your body
link is also in the description listen
to it not watch it you can't watch it
yet maybe we will someday in the future
if you support it
bob wade and i are really fun to be with
you'll enjoy it distractible
it's good fun okay thank you every
monday new episode thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you